servus skills und herzlich willkommen zu
einem neuen video in dem ich heute 5
live hacks in minecraft vorstellen
möchte so bevor wir zu den live hacks
selbst kommen muss ich vorher noch sagen
dass ich ja ein spieler bin der einige
minecraft im pvp angefangen hat und seit
dem motto papier gemacht hat das heißt
man muss wissen außerhalb von pvp ist
eigentlich relativ gering und ich habe
heute 5 live hacks ausgewählt die ich
persönlich noch nicht kannte und die für
mich was neues waren deswegen kann es
gut sein dass du wenn du schon viel
ahnung von minecraft ist die
wahrscheinlich schon erkennt und ihr
denken okay was soll das jetzt deswegen
wenn du richtig viel ahnung von
minecraft hast ist das wahrscheinlich
nicht das richtige für dich aber du
kannst du stolz machen schauen wie viel
du kanntest davon sind glaube ich
parcours dabei wie gesagt alle minecraft
froh es da draußen für euch ist das
wahrscheinlich das richtige video und
schreib bitte keine kommentare unter
sowie djourou gesperrt war und wie oft
und in die rhone wird heute das wissen
wir glaube ich besser so hier mein
schöner ozean alles klar
und da tauchen jetzt mal runter und ja
gut von oben haben wir natürlich in
clearwater shader aber wenn wir
abtauchen sehen wir da ist nix mit
waidsee so und da kommt live act nummer
eins ins spiel dafür brauchen wir einen
tageslicht sensor
schild und irgendwie 2 block vorwand
dafür nehmen jetzt auch immer dann
stellen wir uns in die richtung die
interessierte platzieren die zwei blöcke
bauer und setzen also auf dem boden
das schild hier dran gut das schild muss
man nicht so beschriften auf jeden fall
wenn wir jetzt hier langsam drauf
snacken und uns genau hier hinstellen
sehen wir dass wir sehr sehr sehr weit
schauen können im vergleich immer das
hier ist die normale sich wenn man so
hier drauf stellen können wir extrem
weit sehen
dahinten erkennen dass er wohl im sumpf
die um ist dann sehen wir links bis an
den rand rechts bis an den rand und
können uns sehr sehr gut im wasser
orientieren und so ist es wieder extrem
trieb sehr sehr praktisch wenn man im
wasser zum beispiel nachgesucht weise
nach dem aber nur drauf stellen und in
einem gewissen winkel sich umschauen man
darf nicht zu sehr ab tauchen bzw
scheinbar schon den tages nichts denn so
brauchte dafür mit einer druckplatte und
im slip hat nicht funktioniert da habe
ich ausprobiert print es ab und wird sie
gesagt
so kommen jetzt live heck nummer zwei
den könnt ihr gut gebrauchen wenn er ein
wunderschönes haus in langjähriger
arbeit errichtet hat so wie das hier ja
wo ist lebens habt ihr investierten
auszubauen
das seien ungefähr so wie das hier
aussieht und jetzt fragt ihr euch okay
sind vielleicht noch andere spieler auf
dem server was kann ich machen um das
haus zu beschützen und eines sehr sehr
coole sache ist live act nummer zwei und
dafür braucht ihr einen kessel bzw
mehrere kasse und entweder ein skelett
oder ein skelett der einfachheit halber
nehmen jetzt einfach mal die skelette
hier weil wir jetzt keine skelette
herumschubsen ball durch die gegend und
dann machte das wie folgt besetzt den
kessel und sport oder schiebt ein
skelett in den kessel ryan und jetzt
seht ihr das ding fing an zu brennen das
ist klar weil die sonne darauf scheint
so wenn wir die kesse jetzt allerdings
auch von der sonne abschirmen
dann verbrennen die skelette nicht und
die bleiben in den kesseln trennen und
das ist relativ witzig weil sie von
selbst nicht raus können das heißt ihr
habt euch quasi geschützte gebaut die
jetzt euer haus verteidigen und wenn die
skelette benennt die spawnen die auch
nicht und das ist eine recht witzige
sache natürlich greifen die euch selbst
auch an selbstverständlich aber wenn ihr
dies gelte vermeidet kann man eigentlich
recht geile sachen machen das ist eine
ganz witzige sachen aber meinen
automatisches geschützt eigentlich nicht
einfacher bauen kann als das hier
live act nummer drei ist porträtierte
sie praktisch die gerne bauen dafür
braucht ihr fackeln und irgendein festen
block dann nehmen wir auch jetzt der
einfachheit halber wiederstein und jetzt
könnt ihr erst mal wie folgt bauen denn
platziert erstmal einstein seine fackel
und macht das ein 23 mal so und jetzt
platziert ihr einfach an der fackel von
außen ein eis reinickend die fackel von
ihrer seite ausbauen sagt zack zack zack
sagt jetzt warten wir ein sekündchen und
in der zeit gehen wir mal ein game und 0
und sehen dass das eis hier anfängt zu
schmelzen und da der eisblock sich beim
schmelzen nicht updated bleibt das
wasser in der position und ist jetzt
einfach so ein wasserwürfel der in der
luft schwebt was eine ziemlich heiße
sache zu bauen wenn man sowas sonst
kommen kriegt und auch ganz witzig ist
um zum beispiel konstruktion zu bauen um
im fall abzufangen das problem jetzt mal
auszubauen sagt mal 60 blöcke hoch
barbara waren also lasst uns miteinander
treffen aber mal gucken ob das glück uns
heut ist und das probieren wir aus ob
diese einzelnen spielen wasser blöcke
unseren sturz abfangen können und das
hat sehr gut funktioniert mit nur vier
eisblöcken haben jetzt hier vier
schwebende wasser blöcke und das sieht
eigentlich an sich auch schon ganz
witzig aus so jetzt kommen wir zur
nummer vier und fünf und nummer vier und
fünf dürften ein bisschen bekannter sein
als die ersten zwei oder die ersten drei
zumindest
vorläufig 4 braucht die mindestens 1
besser drei namensschilder und einen
amboss und was wir es machen wir
benennen die namensschilder um und zwar
in einmal den ball einmal in gramm und
ein mal soll die frage ist was
kommentiert machen dafür suchen uns mal
hier mob oder in der gegend die dinger
bohnen gramm namensschilder haben den
gleichen effekt wer die navi auf dem
motto spiel auf dem billiger oder eine
kuh oder eben in hunan wendet dann
werden die dinge auf den kopf gestellt
was je nachdem ob durchaus ganz witzig
wurde auch für wirklich aussehen kann
ist klar da unten wird in china da
natürlich messprogramm alles klar
jetzt wollen uns man fährt hier das
nennen wir den ball so und jetzt mal
ausprobieren
das problem werde die bombe auf dem kopf
zu zähmen was ganz normal funktionieren
wird soll er das pferd ist gezähmt wie
ihr ziel im sattel auf und jetzt haben
wir unser eigenes pferd von können mit
einem pferd was auf dem kopf stehend
durch die gegend reiten ist jetzt nicht
die schlechteste sache würde ich sagen
wenn wir jetzt allerdings absteigen und
es noch mal ein schaf suchen können wir
da vorne auch das dritten tag an wänden
und zwar wenn wir das game tag auf den
schlaf anwenden das wissen
wahrscheinlich schon einige dämpfer weil
es geschafft in regenburg scharf front
in regenbogenfarben an
für den letzten live x5 brauchen wir
gold äpfel beziehungsweise braucht nicht
zwingend gold äpfel aber wir brauchen
auf jeden fall oxidieren auf jeden fall
ändern perlen idealerweise eine diamant
rüstung und ein feuerzeug die meisten
werden schon geahnt haben wir zimmern
uns damit ein kleines reporter es
juristen angehen
durch das portal sobald man satzende pro
tag bzw im doppelten satz zack steppen
oder besuchen uns jetzt immer hier ein
etwas höher gelegenes plätzchen zum
beispiel dass hier wechseln in den game
mode 0 und probiert mal den trick aus
dazu haben uns jetzt noch kurz den
goldenen apfel reingezogen und jetzt
problem wir unser glück auf das dach von
der dazu kommen und spam einfach wie
wild und haben es geschafft und die lava
kann sich sehr gut gab es geschafft
wissen auf dem dach von da drauf und das
alles mit dem satz normaler gold äpfel
und ender perlen also alles items man
bekommen kann
und jetzt haben wir hier eine menge
platz um unseren kam zu machen können
wie viel platzieren was auch ganz neues
theoretisch kann man sie auch ein haus
auf dem dach von selber bauen denn es
gibt auch tricks wie man durch den
betrieb wieder zurückkommt aber das
vielleicht einem anderen video für heute
war es das und wer selbst noch in den
film ich mag es live exakt die jetzt und
nicht vorgestellt von dir gerne der welt
mitteilen möchte dann könne die gerne
die kommentare schreiben
sollte ich mal video machen werdet ihr
auf jeden fall dran erwähnt wer hier
vorkommt und dank fürs zuschauen bis zum
nächsten mal rein macht's gut und ja